what I got here is I got some plywood
some rough cut two-by-fours I'm gonna
lay this out my goal here is is to be
efficient with my materials you know try
to make my dog houses out of one sheet
of plywood per dog house when winter
comes you got to constantly maintain
your dogs houses clean them out once a
week trying to set the house up to where
it's easy to do that very functionable I
need the door up high so the straw stays
in there and they're not dragging the
straw out so to finish that up I use a
handsaw huh that way keep a nice clean
cut I got a feeling that the dogs are
gonna be pretty excited about this this
is the time of year you got to get
everything done in Alaska because
winter's coming
you can smell it in the air the fire
weed starting to lose all its flowers
and balloons so times come in that the
dogs got to have houses they got to be
dry okay what I'm gonna do next is get
my two-by-fours measured out cut and I'm
going to slap one together make sure my
design sound I don't ever really go up
the plan or blueprint I just got it in
my mind what I want to do is just
playing with numbers and laying things
out these are the pieces that I will use
to line the roof and the floor with so
everything will firmly attach just ties
it in structure with
with my plywood that I have I had to
like think to be like efficiently and
plan out my usage of my wood I got the
stack of wood that's what I got I don't
have a lot of waste for building dog
houses you know I view it it's just a
simple thing like building a smokehouse
it's you know built to shelter the dog
it's not a piece of artwork if you build
the doghouse it's not necessarily
permanent but you know to take good care
of them they could last five six years
dog house number one
what you doing Oh ginger is it you give
the duck house to the dog she's in it
right away she must like it that to it
just getting started